Hà Nội và các cú vực phụ cận được sự báo sẽ đón lượng lớn căn hộ mới trong những năm tới,
sau mở chuyên gia cảnh báo, khả năng hấp phụ của thị trường có thể gặp khó, khi nguyên cùng chủ yếu thuộc phần khúc giá càng.
Theo các lần bị nghiên cứu, từ năm 2020, thị trường căn hộ hà Nội có thể ghi nhận hạn chục nghiệp sản phẩm mới mỗi năm,
tập chung tại cú vực phía đông tủ đồ và các địa bản lên cận.
Nếu giữa an quy mô lớn đang được đẩy nhàng tiến độ mở bán, ngày sau khi hoàn tất thủ tục pháp liy,
có phần làm một cung tăng mạnh. Tuy nhiên, phần lớn căn hộ cho bán đều thuộc phần cú cào cấp hạn sang,
với mức giá nèo ở nữ cao, sau với tuy nhập bị quần của người dân.
Dữ liệu thì chường cho thấy giá bán căn hộ kể cả tại cú vực phụ vên đã tăng nhàng trong những năm cạnh đây,
trong khi phần cú nhẹ ở vừa tủ tiền gần như vấn bóng.
Các chuyên gia nhận định khi giá bán vừa xa khả năng trí trạ của số đông,
thì chường có mý cơ dơ vào trạng thái bóng hà, khách khoản xuyếu.
Thực kế này đã giá yêu cầu phải cơ cấu lại môn cùng, hướng tới đáp ứng yêu cầu ở thường.
Chức kinh hình trên nhiều ý kiến cho rằng nhả nước cần tiếp tục hoàn thiệt cơ chế chính xác,
nhằm quyến khích phán trên nhà ở thương mại giá vụ hợp,
sau mong vấn nhà ở xa hội, quái đó có phần cân bán cung cầu và bảo đạm sự ồn định,
mẹn vướng của thị trường và đậu xa.